what's up everybody my name is o'hara
and today we're gonna talk about the man
the myth the legend red hair shanks and
his purpose in the story of one piece
i think it's pretty fair to say that
shanks is one of the most liked and
wildly celebrated characters in the
entirety of the one piece story
in all six popularity polls that were
conducted until today
shanks always easily placed within at
least
the top 15. to put this into perspective
on average shanks is more popular than
usopp
brook or even frankie all of which have
been an
active part of the story for hundreds of
chapters
shanks meanwhile is mentioned in less
than 30 chapters
and appears in less than 15. 15 chapters
out of roughly a thousand let that sink
in for a moment
however despite his lack of screen time
it's relatively
easy to see what makes shang so
fascinating
oda portrays the yonko as a charismatic
leader
that despite his goofy and oftentimes
easygoing nature
is respected and feared throughout the
world and is one of the most
influential players there at the same
time the quite rare occasions his name
is dropped and the even rarer
appearances he actually has
shroud his character in a sense of
mystery and uncertainty
this extremely appealing character
design
has led to countless theories over
shanks's true role in the story
is he actually a celestial dragon will
he die at the hands of blackbeard
or will he ultimately turn out to be the
main villain of the story after all
what will this mysterious and legendary
pirate that we've known since the very
first chapter of the story
actually be doing in the end in this
video we will answer
all of these questions because if you
look closely enough
at how oda is placing shanks in the
story it becomes clear that the yonko is
presented as something
that you could call the secret guardian
of the one piece world
this can be seen in his strikingly
pacifistic nature
his unique and inherent goodness among
the yonko
as well as in his undeniable ties to
nordic mythology and lore
once we'll have looked at these three
factors at the end of this video
we'll be able to see clearly what role
shanks
actually plays in the story so grab
yourself some coffee
because we have to talk about akagamino
when you hear the word pacifist the
first thing you probably think about in
the context of one piece
are the parsi fista created by dr
vegapunk
however when we look at the definition
of pacifism it becomes
relatively clear that something went
horribly wrong with the world
government's naming scheme here
because a pacifist per definition is a
person who believes that unnecessary war
and violence
are unjustifiable not exactly fitting
when you look at whatever this is now
with shanks on the other hand
this is a completely different story he
is a true pacifist
that tries to avoid unnecessary conflict
and violence if in
any way possible this is even
acknowledged by the gorosei
who state that he's not the type of
person that would see
chaos and disorder however that of
course does not mean that shanks does
not enjoy some friendly sparring here in
them
as he clearly does with mihawk or
against the whitebeard pirates as a
rookie on roger's ship
however compared to most other pirates
and similarly to luffy
shanks doesn't seem to have any interest
in pointless cruelty or bloodshed
but i believe that it goes even further
than this shanks
seems to have an active interest in
keeping the quite fragile balance of the
one piece world alive
this becomes clear when he steps in to
stop the war at marine fort
or whenever he expresses his deep
worries about blackbeard
in this context one of shanks's most
stunning skills that he rarely gets any
credit for
is his deep understanding of diplomacy
none other than shanks is able to stop a
war between the marines and another
yonko
or get a private audience with the
gorosei all while being one of the most
notorious criminals on the planet
but we can also see this sort of
de-escalating and effective diplomacy
in other instances as well for example
he's meeting with whitebeard to discuss
the danger of blackbeard
or his notoriously forgiving attitude
towards higuma
a mere mountain bandit from the east
blue that tried to humiliate him in
front of his men
and maybe he even managed to find a
diplomatic solution in his encounter
with kaido
where he somehow managed to stop the
yonko from going off the
and afterwards arrives at marineford
without so much as a scratch
it's entirely possible that what all of
these examples
clearly show us however is how averse
chance truly is to unjust bloodshed and
unnecessary
violence however as we all know just too
well
shanks also has another side whenever
his ideals and values are being
threatened
shanks is ready to take up arms and
deliver justice
notoriously of course we can see this
once higuma
actually takes things a little bit too
far and kidnaps and threatens luffy
or when arriving at marineford shanks is
prepared to face akainu and the marines
head on
should they refuse to lay down their
weapons and everyone is
more than reluctant to test him and his
crew this could even have played a role
in his encounter with kit
where the supernova lost an arm to the
yonko given his character
it's entirely possible that kit did
something so unjust or cruel
that shang saw it necessary to bestow
justice upon him
this striking duality of diplomatic
pacifism
and unwavering justice are a defining
part of shanks's character but to truly
understand this unique position of his
in the world of one piece
we of course also have to understand his
equally unique standing
among the yonko
there are a number of things that make
shanks the odd one out when it comes to
his membership within the four
strongest and most feared pirates for
instance
as far as we know he's the only one of
the four that is not commanding an
entire fleet and we're also yet to come
across any island that stands under his
protection or rule
also shanks is the only one that
evidently has not
eaten any devil fruit and weirdly enough
he's also the only one
not associated with the rocks pirates in
any way with
big mom and kaido being former members
and blackbeard having served on
whitebeard's crew
as well as naming his ship after him i
feel like this
already tells us quite a lot about him
as he's also the only yonko
that has never opposed luffy and has no
interest in gaining more power
nor in becoming pirate king in more than
just
one way it doesn't take a lot of deep
analysis
to come to the conclusion that shanks is
the only emperor that can be considered
to be
quote unquote good at this point in the
story he was the one inspiring luffy to
become a pirate and setting out to see
believing that he will be the one to
change the world one day
for the better his attempts to keep
blackbeard and kaido
at bay suggest to us that chang sees
himself as a sort of
counterweight to the other yonko to
maintain stability in the worlds
using his power and staying true to his
theme of war and justice
shanks works to protect the world by
ensuring a stability and balance between
all the forces at work there whether he
does so to even the way for luffy
or to follow some other objective we'll
have to wait and see
however oda might have left us a couple
of major hints towards
what shang's storyline is moving towards
and these hints can be found
in the close connection that he has to
nordic mythology
in nordic mythology there exists the
legend of tyr
the god of war and justice that once
ruled over the other gods before odin
when the giant wolf fenrir son of loki
was prophesized to kill odin
the gods took him to asgard and
attempted to bind and control him
fenrir however whom they told it would
be a mere test of his strength
would only permit them to put the chains
on him if one of them
were to be willing to put his arm
between his fangs as insurance
now none of the gods were willing to do
so except for tyr
who strode forward and placed his arm in
the wolf's mouth
once henry had actually realized that he
could not escape
he bit off tears arm who thus managed to
uphold justice
and order at the same time does this
sound familiar yet
however the similarities do not end here
shanks and tyr both
are renowned for their swordsmanship
their sense of justice
as well as their red hair and not for
nothing the shank's sail on a viking
ship
i think it's pretty likely that oda has
borrowed at least
some inspiration for shanks's character
from this nordic gauze
and interestingly enough tyr has been
prophesized to be killed by grummer at
drachna rock
the great battle to end the era of the
gods
grommer is a huge hellhound often
depicted with three heads
and i think you know where i'm going
with this but blackbeard and shanks have
long been set up to clash at some point
in the future and there simply are so
many striking similarities here
shanks was the first one to take
blackbeard very seriously very early on
he already noticed something strange
about him when they first met as
apprentices
on rogers and whitebeard's ship he later
encountered him again at some point
where he was dealt the scar across his
eyes and finally
he's the one to urge whitebeard and
possibly even the gorosei
to take teach more seriously
thematically
this storyline would fit perfectly and
we also know that elbaf
is heavily inspired by nordic culture
and mythology as well
with all the viking themes going around
there and when we meet the very first
giants in the story on little garden
dory and brogi
they say the following to usopp when
there's a dispute
and neither side will yield the god of
elbaf decides the matter
our god protects the one who's right and
lets him live
could shanks possibly not only be
inspired by the god of war and justice
but actually be considered a true god by
the people of elbaf